I can advise your husband quite a bit
keep his mouth shut and stay the hell
out of the way
[Music]
TGIF y'all welcome to certified country
I am so happy the weekend is here
because this week has literally been all
over the map but I can't complain
because my job is so awesome and I got
to spend some quality time with three of
the biggest stars in country music right
now who also just so happened to be some
of the nicest guys I caught up with
Jason Aldean in Los Angeles then flew to
Vegas to see Luke Bryan and I met up
with Dierks Bentley in Denver Mama's
tired but not as tired as this guy the
ACMs reigning Entertainer of the Year
just released his new album rearview
town and he's running on no sleep with a
new baby at home here's Jason Aldean and
his I heart country album release party
what's it been like having a little boy
in the house it's cool you know I mean I
love being a dad to girls and I didn't
really know any different you know and
and I love that but I think every guy
kind of wants to a little a little boy
that's kind of like his little shadow
you know it right now he doesn't really
do much he just kind of lays there and
eats a lot and you know sleeps and cries
and those all that stuff so I'm kind of
just ready for him to get a little older
so we could kind of hang out a little
bit but but he's awesome he's great you
make
[Music]
[Applause]
making
talking about your duet with Miranda
Lambert we kind of came up in the
business together we toured a lot
together early on in my career and I
just I don't know I just always felt
like our voices sounded really really
good together and and so I had an idea
to to do something with her own this
record and I sent her the song and the
first song I sent her she was like yeah
you know and I was like all right listen
if you don't like it I don't want to cut
it you know I want to make sure whatever
we do you love it and so I said I got
this other song and I sent it to her and
it was a song called rounds of whiskey
and and she loved that when it's a
little bit more of a traditional side
and so she came in and and just it was
already a great song but once she got on
it just kind of sent it over the top
first album you ever purchased mountain
music Alabama okay first concert you
attended Kenny Rogers and the Gatlin
Brothers song currently spinning on
repeat it's probably my record I've been
sort of dissecting my own album as
probably why I had been listening to the
radio much rearview 10 I loved the title
track
[Music]
if you weren't an artist you'd probably
be doing what I probably be doing
something in the sports world like a
sportscaster or a sports writer last one
is one thing we've never guessed by
looking at you I'm actually a master of
ironing clothes really Luke knows a
thing or two about that
he's a doting dad himself and was sweet
enough to give my pregnant belly a
little rub for good luck he didn't have
any advice for me as a new mom but he
did have a message for dad talking about
your husband quite a bit now that you
are judging and critiquing young artists
on a public scale does it put more
pressure on you to really bring it in
your own performance well yeah I mean I
think you have pressure every time
you're onstage nothing with critiquing
young people is just try to try to lift
them up I mean I always worked better
when people encouraged it's just fun for
me it's very inspiring to be around
young talent and to see the the light in
their eyes and the excitement of trying
to capture this music dream because I
remember that feeling about Blake - I
know there's been a lot of competition
between the two of you each other when
the shows are on what's what's it gonna
be like when you see him here well I'm
gonna knock him out and you know we you
know Blake was really really excited
when I got the Idol gig and we you know
we don't look at it that way obviously
you know I want American Idol to be a
huge success we work hard at it and like
I said we know how successful the voice
is - and you know the fact that they're
two shows similar but they're really
really different and we go about it much
differently and I think fans will you
know go back and forth and watch both
and you know I'm not out for like I said
to take down the voice but I kind of do
want to take down Blake
last but certainly not least Dierks
Bentley is busy gearing up for
upcoming seven peaks music festival in
Colorado so he should be the ropes of
glamping to prepare hi Dirk how you
doing good congratulations by the way
thank you so much so rough landing
coming in today yeah that's a little
windy here as you can tell the power's
knocked out here yes so we were supposed
to be in Buena Vista Colorado today to
talk about the seven peaks festival but
the wind would not allow us to be there
so here we are in Denver auditorium
quickly I want to go through some of
your camping slash festival yes tabs
there's me oh canoe on the top of my bus
like grill smoke coming out the back and
we're loading this thing down because
it's not just the festivals it's play
time so you got up your mountain bikes
got all your toys right you gotta have
your American flag trunks you do see
these a lot of these at stagecoach like
all the guys actually they're about this
short though this speedo I don't do that
my were kneeling Oh full-coverage you
might want to work on a new instrument
you have your bongos for late-night
Bongo session or yeah I must have for
you right let's talk about your music I
think it's a Thursday we'll be hearing
the mountain on stage yes yes definitely
near the mountain the last songs were
inspired just by by the mountains being
out in the mountains where the mountains
make you feel you know make you feel
alive and happy and grateful
[Music]
did your wife and your kids inspire any
other songs on the album oh gosh I mean
they inspire everything everything
everything is inspired by as you'll find
out
everything's inspired by the kids I
don't write songs specifically about
kids or about that but it you know if
you hear a love song of mine you may
think it's about my wife or girl baby
could be about one of my kids too it's
like that in big woody I love that a man
that I am today I mean this the amount
of character building that comes from
being a father is crazy I mean it's just
who I am now who I was nine years ago
before Evy is a joke I mean I just some
I'm such a stronger person today been a
boy and I've been a man of both sides of
the fence and I can still go onstage and
act like a boy every night that's a lot
of fun but you can't be a man unless
you've you know you've had kids it's
just got about criteria Dirk's is
Inaugural seven peaks festival is
happening over Labor Day weekend in
Buena Vista Colorado and you can see
more from that interview on Fridays
Entertainment Tonight broadcast and on
ET online.com but first
California's Country Music Festival
stagecoach is set to begin next week on
April 27 Florida Georgia line Keith
Urban and Garth Brooks are headlining
with stars like Kelsea Ballerini
Brothers Osbourne Kacey Musgraves
and Kayne Brown also performing for more
on that and an interview with one of the
campus performers come back and see us
again next week we'll be right here on
YouTube
you